between the free cities and the bones
between the Shivering sea and slavers
Bay spreads the Dothraki sea named not
for its waters but for how freely it's
conquerors roam upon it a traveler on
the Dothraki sea will find few villages
and no farms because the Dothraki view
it is a sin to cut into their mother
earth with plows and shovels and the
Dothraki know only one punishment the
closest the Dothraki approach to
civilization is by Stoff rack though to
outsiders it doesn't look like a city
there are no walls because the Dothraki
believe only cowards hide behind them
instead of facing an enemy blade in hand
but the Dothraki couldn't do that here
either within the bounds of the city no
one not even the mightiest car may carry
a blade by order of the priestesses of
the - Cali not that any enemy would be
foolish enough to attack the sacred city
of the Dothraki in the first place -
giant bronze stallions rear over the
entrance to the city their hooves
meeting in the air to form an arch the
famous horse gate through it is the
God's Way but the Dothraki dragged the
sacred idols of the cities and peoples
they've broken along one side stone gods
look down and you from crack Thrones
with chipped and stained faces their
names lost to time across the road
monsters what she pasts black iron
dragons with jewels for eyes roaring
Griffin's manticores with bobtails
poised to strike another terrible beasts
from every corner of Essos but there is
nothing to fear if these gods and devils
had any power
it would never have ended here not all
foreign gods envious Dothrak are broken
in the famous eastern and western
markets merchants worship their God have
trade with the sufferance of the
Dothraki who themselves don't understand
buying and selling the Western market is
a great square of beaten earth filled
with animal pens drinking holes and a
maze of stalls and crooked aisles even
goods from Westeros find their way here
though the merchants who sell them
wouldn't know a Lannister from a frame
the eastern market is fittingly a
stranger place the elders of the -
Colleen viewed with suspicion the most
of Rakhi stay away they aren't wrong the
great elephants the basilisks and silver
cages from the striped black and white
horses of the yoga's Nighy are harmless
enough but I can see how the elders
wouldn't want their younger members to
see the warrior maids of here [ __ ] who
wear iron rings in their nipples and
rubies in their cheeks
or listen to the shadow men who covered
their bodies with tutus and hide their
faces behind masks and whisper dark
secrets for a price
this is all advised ah frak that
foreigners ever know
for only Dothraki are permitted into the
inner city where the dosh killeen live
out their lives a blood rider drunk on
fermented mares milk once told me that
the dosh Kelleen are stewards they
prepare for the day when every rider of
every khalasar shall return to the city
and the Dothraki truly will be one blood
and one callus are again under the
greatest karl of all the stallion who
mounts the world he will ride to the
ends of the earth and grind nations into
dust and take a whole world as his herd
or so the prophecy goes yet the world is
vast with many places a horse can't go a
stallion who mounts the world couldn't
rear above a mountain range or leap
across the sea still the world has been
conquered before just not with stallions